how did our solar system originate nasa
has launched a new mission to try and
answer that question lucy lifted off
from the kennedy space center in florida
the probe will spend the next 12 years
studying asteroids near the planet
jupiter the space rock is leftover
debris from the formation of our solar
system let's hope the close encounters
will reveal clues about how we got here
one hour after takeoff
lucy is set to unfold its solar panels
each one has a diameter of more than
seven meters
the enormous size of these panels gives
lucy the energy needed to penetrate
deeper into our solar system than any
other previous space probe
lucy is headed to jupiter and the
so-called trojan asteroids that circle
it
these celestial bodies are locked into
jupiter's orbit around the sun by the
planet's intense gravity field
the trojan asteroids are distributed in
two separate elongated regions situated
ahead of and behind jupiter images from
the hubble space telescope show that
these asteroids might originate from
different places in the solar system
they have different colors and reflect
light differently
the asteroids appeared about four and a
half billion years ago they're thought
to have originated in the early days of
the solar system's formation
but the asteroids are still made up of
their original matter whereas the
planets have continued to evolve over
the years
the space probe lucy is set to observe a
total of seven asteroids to achieve this
it must negotiate some complex flight
maneuvers first it will gain momentum by
circling the earth twice before it
launches out into deep space
the journey will take until august 2027
once in deep space lucy will be able to
observe the first four asteroids during
a flyby
then it will set cores for earth where
it will once again gain momentum for a
second journey to gather information on
a different cluster of asteroids
the spacecraft is programmed to observe
the surface of these different worlds
searching for ice and substances that
may have led to forms of life
scientists hope it can help them
research the possible origins of matter
they're hoping this will shine new light
on the early stages of our solar system
interesting stuff and let's keep talking
about it with keith cowing he's in
washington dc he's an astrobiologist who
used to work for nasa and is now the
editor of nasa watch a blog about the
american space program welcome mr cowing
so just how groundbreaking is the launch
of lucy
well normally when you have a mission
like this to visit an asteroid it's
maybe an asteroid or maybe two if you're
lucky and if everything works well maybe
a third and this spacecraft is going to
be seeing uh seven eight nine
there are other asteroids you could see
in addition to these but this is like a
whole bunch of them and they're of all
different types and as was mentioned in
your introductory piece some of these
asteroids may be in the same place
they've been for billions and billions
of years before planets form which was
as mentioned something really exciting
you're getting to see the lego blocks
out of which planets formed
why do you think we need to study these
trojan asteroids
well again they are they're potentially
building blocks from which all the
planets we now have earth uh venus mars
and so forth were formed and we know
what we have today and the mystery's
always been how did all this stuff come
together to form planets and this is
really a fundamental question of you
know planetology is where do we come
from and of course at the same time many
of the substances that form life as we
know it on earth are now being found on
a variety of small bodies comets and
asteroids around the solar system and
the question is how did all those
chemicals carbon water oxygen and so
forth how did they come to the earth and
these bodies may represent freeze frozen
examples of what once bombarded the
earth with the chemicals that eventually
became us
so the probe will spend the next 12
years studying these asteroids when will
we potentially get any answers regarding
all of this that you're just talking
about
well it's going to take several years to
get to the first batch of these things
so you know go on with your business uh
yeah there's not going to be any news
tomorrow
but uh but
as this stuff starts to come in it'll be
it'll become something where
if you were in fifth or sixth grade uh
by the time you got out of high school
it would not be unusual for you to know
about eight new worlds that uh all we
know right now is that they're orbiting
their head or behind a jupiter in their
little point of light
so we're we're going to just expand even
further the knowledge we have of the
solar system within which we live and
also as we're discovering planets around
other stars these asteroid types will be
found there too so we're learning
something about other star systems at
the same time
uh very briefly if you can where is
modern space exploration generally
headed under president biden will we
really see the first woman on the moon
by 2024
by 2024 i i sincerely doubt that and
that's just a matter of scheduling and
funding i think that the trump folks had
a
in washington we call it an aspirational
goal you know put something on the wall
the name toward it and uh and the money
and everything else didn't quite make it
the rockets are late so um
uh will it be within a few years of that
absolutely now that's nasa it could be
that elon musk decides that he can just
he's building a lander for nasa but he
decided to use one of his other rockets
and just go there himself he could go
there sooner
we'll see
well we keep talking to you as we
approach that date keith cowing
astrobiologist and formerly with nasa
thank you so much for your time
my pleasure